hago boxing ofrece de era un científico
como hemos venido sabiendo en las
últimas horas tal vez uno de los
científicos más importantes de irán
también era un guardia revolucionario
como lo confirmaron hoy y este hombre
tenía a cargo parte del programa nuclear
iraní lo que sucede es que tanto estados
unidos como israel lo acusan de haber
estado a cargo de la investigación de un
posible proyecto de armas nucleares que
irán siempre ha negado a pesar de que se
dice que ese programa de investigación
se terminó en el 2003 también lo señalan
de haber estado investigando proyectos
que estaban totalmente subterráneos irán
como vuelvo a decir ha negado
absolutamente pero sí hemos sabido de la
importancia de este hombre que tenía a
su cargo toda la investigación del
ministerio de defensa no solamente en el
proyecto nuclear sino en otro tipo tipo
de armas y también como lo dijo el
presidente de hasan rohan y hoy también
investigaba sobre el cob y estaba a
cargo de la vacuna el proyecto que
investiga la vacuna y los kits de
atención rápida que tenía hablemos de la
repercusión
tanto a nivel político como social irán
ya sabemos como decíamos estaba
apuntando a israelí sea prometió
venganza por otro lado hay
manifestaciones en el país verdad
si hay manifestaciones especialmente del
ala más radical que es la que ha salido
a la calle en estos tiempos de comida
pedir que no haya que no haya
negociaciones con eeuu en un posible
gobierno de joe biden pero hay una cosa
importante no solamente se ha acusado a
israel de estar detrás de este asesinato
sino que hace unos minutos desde la
organización de energía atómica también
se vincula a ese mismo equipo de
personas que mataron a farixa de con el
ataque a la planta de natanz a el pasado
agosto que llevó a que estas
centrifugadoras que enriquecen el uranio
pasarán a una parte subterránea que
hayan creado otra vez dudas sobre las
intenciones de irán con este proyecto
nuclear así que irán ha dicho que con
cautela que ellos no van a responder por
el momento que no van a caer en la
trampa de israel que quiere crear un
caos antes de que se vaya el presidente
donald trump pero la presión es muy
grande en el país y desde todas las
instancias se pide venganza